In this problem, acetone is produced at
a rate of 3,200 gall per day and
transferred into a 25,000galon storage
tank that is blanketed with nitrogen.
The tank is maintained at 35° C and 760
mm of mercury absolute pressure. The
displaced vapor from the tank is routed
to a refrigerated condenser operating at
-10° C before venting to the atmosphere.
Relevant data for the acetone are
provided below. The molecular weight is
58.08
g per mole. The vapor pressure of
acetone at 35° is 420 mm of mercury. The
vapor pressure of acetone at -10° C is
70 mm of mercury.
Assume ideal gas behavior and that
nitrogen is inert. What is the amount of
acetone condensed in the condenser in
pounds per day?
So today we're going to figure out how
much acetone condenses when it's
transferred into a tank and the vapor is
cooled in a condenser.
So acetone is being produced at 3,200 g
per day
and goes into a 25,000gal storage tank.
The tank is blanketed with nitrogen kept
at 35° C and 760 mm of mercury.
The displaced vapor goes through a
refrigerated condenser at -10°.
We want to know how many pounds per day
of acetone actually condenses in that
condenser.
So let's break this into steps.
Step one,
we need to find the mole fraction of
acetone.
So the mole fraction of acetone in the
gas is going to be equal to y a for
acetone
and that's going to equal the pressure
of acetone
over the total pressure.
So in this problem, that's going to be
420 mm of mercury over 760 total
pressure
or 0.553.
We'll call that y a1.
Now y a2 is going to be
the mole fraction after the condenser.
So we were given 420 before the
condenser at 35° and at -10° that's
going to be 70 over 760 or
0.092.
Just as a reminder of what's actually
going on, we can see that since there's
less as vapor here than here,
this is the process by which it's
condensing.
So before the condenser, more than half
of the gas molecules are acetone vapor.
After the condenser, only about 9%
remains in the vapor. So the rest is
condensing.
Step two, let's find the volume of the
incoming acetone.
So the incoming liquid acetone is
pushing the gas out of the tank. So the
volume of the displaced gas is going to
be equal to the volume of the incoming
acetone.
We are given the rate of
3,200
gallons per day.
And from there we can convert that to
lers since we will need that in our next
step. So according to our unit
conversion we can find in the reference
manual we have 3.785
L
per gallon giving us
12,112
lers per day in our acetone. So every
day about 12,000 L of gas is displaced
by the incoming acetone. And we'll just
note that this
is a reference manual conversion.
So step three, we're going to find the
total moles of the displaced gas.
So we're going to convert this gas
volume into moles using the ideal gas
law.
This is going to come from our reference
manual.
On page 204, there's a table provided
that lists the units of volume,
temperature, and the term n, as well as
the units of pressure, and will give you
the relevant n value that you will need
to match up with your other units. So we
can see that our unit
of pressure is going to be in atm.
This is because
mm of mercury
equals
atm. Our volume is in liters, which is
why we converted that before.
And our temperature
in units of Kelvin
is going to be
35°
Celsius plus
or 38°
Kelvin. Given these things, if we look
through that table on page 204 of the
reference manual, we can see that our R
value is going to be equal to 0.08
257.
Now, how do we apply this? We're going
to use the ideal gas law. Just above
that table we have the equation provided
of P V= N RT.
If we rearrange
we can say N equ=
P V over R T. Filling this out we can
see that our 1 ATM will be the P. Our V
is going to be
LERs per day.
Our R is going to be 0.082057
with units of lers
atm over
moles
dash Kelvin.
and our temperature is going to be
308°
Kelvin.
Now if we look at what we have here for
units, we can see that atm will cancel,
lers will cancel and Kelvin will cancel.
The only things that won't are moles and
day. So when we calculate this out, we
should get 479
moles per day.
And that's the moles of the displaced
gas. So let's clean this up a little
bit.
Step one, two,
three,
and now four.
So we have the moles of the displaced
gas. Now, we're going to find the moles
of the acetone that is condensed.
So, we have 479
moles per day times our partial pressure
differences here of
0.553
subtracting
0.092.
And these numbers come from our first
step one of our mole fraction.
This will give us about 220
moles per day. And that's how many
actually condense each day. Finally,
we're going to convert moles to pounds.
So 220
moles per day times
our molecular weight provided over here
of
58.08 08
g
per mole
times
another unit conversion which can be
found in the reference manual of
1 lb over
453.6
g.
This will calculate out to
28.17
pounds
per day. Our closest answer is the
second one listed of 28.
So to summarize this problem, we first
need to calculate the mole fractions
from the vapor pressures.
Then we need to convert the liquid
inflow to the displaced gas volume.
Next, we need to use the ideal gas law
to get the total moles of displaced gas.
And finally, we need to multiply by the
change in mole fraction before and after
the condenser to get the amount of moles
that are condensed. And then finally, we
convert those to pounds. It's a lot of
steps, and you definitely need to
remember a little bit of the ideal gas
law as well as recognize where to find
it in the manual. I would say this is
probably one of the harder problems that
I would experience. Hopefully most of
you out there are more familiar with
this area of environmental engineering
than I am. But just practice it a few
times and it will get more familiar. And
that's it.